this week's episode of Theory Thursday
we have five insanely good theories to
talk about regarding spider-man far from
home Avengers in game the upcoming Black
Widow movie plus a lot more how's it
going everyone it's Warren and welcome
to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where you all
submit your theories I choose 5 to go
over each week you all vote on which one
you thought was your favorite and then
at the end of the month you all vote on
which one you thought should win the
overall month if you would like to send
in your own theory for a chance to end
up in an episode of Theory Thursdays you
can find the email to send it to and the
instructions in the description down
below remember don't forget to vote on
your favorite Theory in the poll at the
end of the video also if you enjoy other
theories you can check out my other
channel cosmic culture where I talk
about a ton of superhero theories ok
like I said we have a ton of really good
theories this week so let's dive right
into them our first theory comes from
Ricky
Stiga and Ricky's theory says that when
cap traveled back in time to return the
stones he somehow got NAT back in
exchange for the soul stone not then
helped him return all the remaining
stones and she also helped him fix all
of the things that they messed up Ricky
says that Captain America did not marry
Peggy because that would change the
future and Mary and Peggy would prevent
her from marrying the husband that she
married when Steve frozen the ice so he
just stopped by to dance with her at the
end then when captain and NAT were ready
to go home they only had one Pym
particle left so they promised to stay
and only return if one of them died
years past a gnat and calf got married
lived a life together until NAT died and
that's when cap returned to inform
everyone that everything was ok this is
why at the end of Avengers in game when
Sam asked about captain's wedding ring
he refused to tell him who the girl was
because it was actually not I have heard
a few different variations of this
theory and I liked it
right now there's sort of a big mess
between what the director said happened
and what the writer said happened but
Peggy and her husband and her kids were
in the main MCU timeline and Captain
America going back in time by the rules
of time-travel according to Avengers in
game that would create an alternate
timeline and Steve Rogers good ol
Captain America would not go back in
time and prevent Peggy Carter from
Marian who she is supposed to marry
and captain and Natasha always had a
little thing going on so I like the idea
that captain actually married Natasha he
got his dance with Peggy but he ended up
marrying Natasha
so that is theory number one on to
theory number two
speaking of Natasha the next theory
comes from Jake Davison who has a theory
about how the Blackwood a movie is going
to play out Jake says that he thinks the
Black Widow movie will take place in the
1990s or the early 2000s and Black Widow
will of course be an assassin in the
movie we will see her take her first
life as in kill somebody for the very
first time we will see them make her an
assassin we will see her training her
first killing and of course Budapest
Jake says that he thinks that we will
see a cameo from somebody that we have
seen before
for example Hawkeye we know that Hawk
guide turns a Natasha good and saves her
life we will most likely see Hawkeye get
ordered to go to Budapest and take down
Nats organization and then he meets NAT
and instead of killing her he decides to
save her Hawkeye will take her under his
wing but he will hide her from shield
and will train her in his own ways then
shield will discover her there will be a
big fight but the movie will end with
her being recruited to shield and the
post-credits scene could tease the
Eternals watching over the world I
definitely think that the Black Widow
movie is going to happen somewhat like
this and I definitely think that we're
going to see Budapest in the Black Widow
movies so that means that we'll probably
see Hawkeye since NAT and Hawkeye both
talked about Budapest a lot and if we
see Hawkeye that means he's definitely
going to try and save Natasha which we
know he eventually does how long this
takes we don't know but this may be the
story that we see in the Black Widow
movie and we recently learned that
taskmaster is going to be the villain so
maybe Hawkeye and Natasha have to team
up to take on taskmaster
so that is theory number two let's move
on to theory number three theory number
three comes from blockout studios and
they have a theory about Mysterio being
the sorcerer supreme in an alternate
universe now I know we've had a lot of
theories about Mysterio being learned in
the mystic arts but this one offers a
different twist to it their theory
states that when Professor Hulk went
back in time and told the ancient one
that dr. strange gave up the time stone
she chose a different sorcerer supreme
mysterio which obviously created a
different timeline the universe ends
getting destroyed due to corruption but
in one last effort Mysterio jumps to the
dimension that the snap created but when
Captain America goes back in time and
returns the time stone this alternate
universe gets destroyed Mysterio is
obviously still alive since he is in the
main universe now however he does learn
that his universe was destroyed but he
thinks it was the elementals that did it
but then Peter tells him that it was
actually Captain America returning the
time stone that killed his universe and
this is when Mysterio becomes the
villain this is a very interesting
theory because in the spider-man far
from home clips and trailers and TV
spots it really does seem like Mysterio
is a good guy him and Peter genuinely
seem like they're best friends and maybe
they truly do start off that way maybe
Mysterio is really trying to help but
then he finds out that his universe was
destroyed because of spider-man and the
rest of the Avengers and then this is
when he becomes the villain he seeks
vengeance because of the destruction of
his universe the screening and the
official premiere for spider-man far
from home have already happened and
people say that there are a few really
big twists and I think pretty much
everyone is expecting Mysterio to be bad
but maybe he is not initially bad and
maybe that's one of the twists is that
his universe was created and then
destroyed due to the aftermath of
Avengers endgame luckily we only have
four more days to wait until we find out
so that was theory number three on to
number four theory number four comes
from Zane h oq with a theory about how
supergiant could be the next villain for
phase four
Zane says my theory is that when Thanos
found out that the Avengers were looking
for the stones he took the black order
with him and at the end of endgame we
see Tony snap his fingers and he kills
Thanos the Chitauri in the black order
but he did not leave his time 2014 alone
he had a back-up plan in case his plan
didn't work out and he was defeated
supergiant was a member that was going
to be included in infinity war but they
ended up cutting her because they gave
Evan e-ma her powers since they didn't
cut heard that means she's still on the
table to be added to the MCU at some
point Zane says if you think about it
vanos is a man who is used to wars so he
put together some reinforcements to
avenge him in case
plan didn't work out supergiant Zayn
says that another thing to think about
is that in the comic supergiant is sent
to Xavier school for the gifted
youngsters to dispatch the x-men in
search of thanasis son this would be a
smart way to introduce the x-men since
the Disney Fox deal is now done and the
x-men can be used in the MCU so a lot of
people were really wondering why they
didn't put supergiant in the black order
in Avengers infinity war or Avengers end
game but now that we've seen Avengers in
game and we know that the present Thanos
dies and the 2014 Thanos goes to the
present time it could make sense that he
left somebody from the black order in
the past and maybe supergiant is the one
that he left behind because it does make
sense that he would want to eventually
go back to 2014 and I would definitely
think that if supergiant found out that
Fanus actually died she would somehow
take command over whatever army is left
and tried to get vengeance and this
could definitely lead to her becoming a
villain in future MCU films so that does
it for a theory number 4 on to the final
theory number 5 the final theory number
5 comes from user dingdong fling flung
and dingdong has a pretty crazy theory
about Captain America returning the soul
stone to bore me
this theory says that what if Black
Widow is still alive what if Steve
actually went back to return the soul
stone to Vermeer but instead he saved
Natasha he could have saved her from
falling off the cliff and sacrificing
herself in Boromir because if he ends up
saving her the soul stone will still be
in Vermeer's ole stone that he has to
Hawkeye this shouldn't really disrupt
the timeline because the soul stone
stays there but Clint still gets a soul
stone as well and what would have
created an alternate timeline is Clint
taking the soul stone from the past but
this way the soul stone stays there but
Clint gets a stone of his own and
Natasha stays alive this theory would
actually make sense because what would
cause the alternate timeline to happen
in the past in 2014 is Clint getting the
soul stone well if Captain America stops
the sacrifice from happening the soul
stone is never taken but of course Clint
still does need a soul stone to bring
back to the present time for the
Avengers to perform the snap but that's
where Captain America gives him the soul
stone the
gistic of it kind of workout but the
fact that Black Widow does not die and
stays alive would in itself create an
alternate timeline but it would be an
alternate timeline where natasha is
alive and the Avengers defeat Thanos so
that is it for this week's theories
let's do a quick recap so you can all
vote on which one was your favorite
theory number one is that Captain
America got Natasha back in exchange for
returning the soul stone the two of them
returned the Infinity stones back in
time but there was only one Pym particle
left so the two of them stayed back in
time and ended up marrying each other
theory number two is how the Black Widow
movie was going to play out and that
Hawkeye is going to make an appearance
in the Black Widow movie theory number
three is that Mysterio was the sorcerer
supreme in his alternate universe the
taking of the time stone is what created
his universe and then when Captain
America put it back it destroyed his
universe he finds this out in spider-man
far from home and then he becomes the
villain theory number four is that
supergiant is going to go on to be a
villain in the MCU and also help
introduce the x-men and theory number
five is that when Steve Rogers went back
in time to return the soul stone to warm
air he ends up saving Natasha and giving
Clint the soul stone so those are this
week's theories be sure to vote on which
one you think is the best one just a
reminder that you should use the poll at
the top of this video to vote because
that's how we choose the winner and
again if you would like to submit a
theory of your own you can find the
email to send it to and the instructions
in the description down below don't
forget to comment with your thoughts
like the video and subscribe to my
channel so you can stay up to date on
all Theory Thursdays and so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
wolf wolf